oh come a holiday so we should get to do  ballet school in his final audition  flicks Razorbacks oh my god will she  ever dance again no more or less your  artistic director Madeline munkar have  you given any thought to my audition I  can never dance again all right i watch  you learn to walk again no one takes 18  months off and expects again to the  National Ballet Company not important  with the right trainers  [Music]  again  come on my life back  you think it's crazy I'm doing  jin-tae  [Music]  in there a chance dancing could make you  sicker what makes me me  evening I'm just game over  [Music]  everything hooks every day you're  hurting yourself and I meant to just let  you  [Music]  we said we did all these on the back  I have no idea what happens next but I'm  excited about finding my own way  you  you